take a bag of pasta and a recipe pops up
including advice from an online
sommelier on what wine pairing works
best at checkout there's no one in sight
everything is scanned automatically
payment is by credit card which is
connected to the car key that's the
future of shopping according to experts
at the research center for artificial
intelligence in sankt vendome who are
exploring new ways to shop forecasters
say Germans will soon spend one out of
every four euros online making it ever
more important for brick-and-mortar
retailers to keep up with technology and
hold on to customers the hunger
retailers have to realize that customers
want information transparency and all
the kinds of service they get when they
shop online the pressure is on for
retailers to go digital with such
features as electronic price tags that
communicate directly with the warehouse
and reorder when necessary at the same
time relevant data can be shown and even
sent to customers mobile devices which
can include information on allergens and
special deals yes armor look we can get
a discount on banana chips of course
customers will have to surrender lots of
information the most Vegas customers
have to sign in maybe with a digital
fingerprint once they're authenticated
the system can upload the shoppers
profile there's a downside to this a lot
of personal data has to be provided but
in the end the customers in control
whoever provides data can enjoy better
service this is a regular supermarket
near the research facility people work
the register customers are on their own
many are skeptical when it comes to the
data driven stores of the future so much
time fatal I want to hear personal
recommendations I want to be able to ask
someone where can I find this or that
it's on paying with your cell phone or
car key I'm not so sure about that I
prefer to just stick to cash or credit
card it's pocketed with all its good
cause it but researchers are certain the
digitization of supermarkets can't be
stopped and that's not the end high-tech
shopping will move into the living room
where goods can be ordered right at the
coffee table some ideas like these will
find their way into retail soon it could
be that products you just saw on TV
could appear on your shopping list
that's the vision for stores of the
future